time travel is complicated after all if
it was simple and straightforward then
everyone would do it sure on paper it
sounds pretty easy to just take a quick
jaunt back to 1890 kill baby adolf and
avert world war ii millions of lives
save before lunch and surely the world
would be all the better for it right but
what if altering history didn't change
the future or the present as you knew it
perhaps instead you unknowingly created
a new alternate timeline branching off
from the history you knew into somewhere
different maybe in this new timeline
where you traveled back in time and
killed hitler someone even worse rises
to power and assumes control of germany
before plunging the world into an even
deadlier war and even that is just one
possible outcome of your singular action
only fitting in with one scientific
theory of how the mechanics of time
travel might work with no certainty that
it actually would happen like that like
we said time travel is nowhere near as
easy as it seems in movies with flying
deloreans and cyborg assassins who
always seem to keep coming back keeping
all that in mind these big perplexing
questions about time travel and
alternate timelines is the perfect segue
into the focus of today's video
introducing scp-1780
which is brace yourselves a plastic name
plate you know the official
business-like kind that you might find
displayed on a desk in a fancy office
wait that's it all that talk of world
ending and the disruption of multiple
dimensional timelines is from this thing
you're probably wondering what on
infinite earths this trivial piece of
office stationary could possibly have to
do with the notion of time travel and we
can tell you that the connection will
likely surprise you
scp-1780 itself appears pretty
unassuming at first showing signs of
aging and damage from being buried for
several decades the first interesting
detail of note however is that
nameplates of this exact style were used
in the offices of the scp foundation
itself from the year 1990 all the way up
as recently as 2003
scp-1780 sports the foundation's emblem
and the lettering on it is still legible
despite the wear and tear while the name
is redacted the rest of it reads phd
chairperson temporal anomalies
department okay so what could be so
important about a nameplate are the
foundation running so low on anomalies
that they have to lock up a harmless
piece of plastic from one of their very
own offices not quite you see you have
already missed the second most
interesting detail about this particular
nameplate not only does the redacted
name not match any previous or existing
staff member on their database but the
scp foundation has never even had a
temporal anomalies department not in
this timeline anyway as for a harmless
nameplate
scp-1780 is certainly anything but that
of course the nameplate itself does
remain inactive if left alone but when
it is placed into a mount of appropriate
size
then
well it's not exactly easy to explain
what happens but we'll try our best
seeing as we're scp explained after all
placing
scp-1780 into a nameplate mound causes a
temporal spatial anomaly to appear in
the nearest doorway this anomaly is
known as scp-1780-1
and according to high-speed photographs
taken by the scp foundation it appears
instantly so fast that its speed can
hardly be measured foundation
researchers are flummoxed as to exactly
how this anomaly appears as well unable
to quantify what it is made of or what
forms it what they do know is that
whatever space was originally behind the
doorway now containing
scp-1780-1 is now inaccessible through
the use of said door however whichever
room was once behind the doorway can
still be accessed by going around the
door either by destroying the adjacent
walls or using another entrance the door
that now contains
scp-1780-1 will remain indestructible
and cannot be accessed while the 1780
nameplate is activated so scp-1780-1
this temporal spatial anomaly what
exactly is it once again that is a
question without an easy answer the best
way to describe it would be to imagine
it as a portal a portal leading where
exactly venturing through a doorway now
hosting scp-1780-1
one will find themselves in an office in
fact this office is an exact match to
one found inside the euclid object's
experimentation wing of site-17 one of
the scp foundation's top secret
containment facilities where they store
a number of dangerous anomalies the
state of the
scp-1780-1 office varies between visits
with signs of misuse neglect and general
disrepair however the interior of this
office always contains the same items
namely there is standard office
furniture the same type and style as
those purchased by the scp foundation
during the renovation of site 17 in
1995.
there are also a number of whiteboards
around the office all with text and
complex mathematical equations written
on them the room also contains a loaded
remington model 870 shotgun a copy of
oxford's unabridged english dictionary
and three copies of time life's great
ages of man a history of the world's
cultures though strangely only one of
these copies matches the history of the
world we know finally there is another
nameplate inside the office a second
instance of scp-1780
complete with a nameplate bracket to
hold it what does this all mean is
scp-1780 capable of opening and closing
portals to just this single office and
where or when is the
scp-1780-1 office is it a pocket
dimension a place in the future
according to tests run by the scp
foundation the multiple
scp-1780 nameplates can be used to
create several simultaneous
scp-1780-1 portals through the use of
gps tracking and other redacted methods
the foundations researchers have been
able to determine that when there are
multiple instances of
scp-1780-1 doorways they will lead to
the same office in the same physical
space
however the different portals will be
separated by an unknown interval of time
so the leading theory is this
the office
scp-1780-1 is somehow temporally
displaced it does not exist within its
proper place in the linear timeline and
could instead be located somewhere
outside time anything left inside the
office space like personal effects or
even members of foundation personnel
that get left behind will vanish if the
portal is closed and reopened as long as
the doorway remains open
scp-1780-1 will behave in harmony with
the normal flow of time as we experience
it but from the moment it closes anyone
left inside the office is considered
irretrievable but that isn't all around
1 in every 10 times that scp-1780 is
used to open the portal into the office
scp-1780-1 will contain something else
not just the items that usually appear
in the office but people well that might
be a bit of a stretch they are humanoids
at least shaped like people referred to
as scp-1780-2
these entities vary dramatically in
their appearance and behavior there is
nevertheless one consistency to them
they will all always claim to be
personnel working for the scp foundation
some of the
scp-1780-2 have alleged themselves to be
site-17 security staff a sign to guard
scp-1780 these entities are usually
passive and cooperative when existing
foundation security interacts with them
others have made the assertion that they
are field agents or researchers assigned
to an unknown project according to them
this project is focused on dealing with
temporal anomalies these as cp
1780-2s tend to behave drastically
differently and are often far more
unpredictable in some cases they have
even been hostile towards foundation
personnel and have even self-terminated
when efforts have been made to contain
them the third and final type of
scp-1780-2 entity seems to be singularly
unique even with its own designation
scp-1780-2
a this entity refers to itself by the
name dr thaddeus zainak and when
questioned by the foundation will refuse
to give any information at all a number
of times personnel have asked this dr
zainak about his origins the goals of
his research even where or when he came
from and every time he hasn't told them
anything of use scp-1780-2
cannot be captured either and seems to
have an in-depth first-hand knowledge of
the foundation he is able to predict all
their containment tactics for hostile
humanoids and has used this foresight to
evade any attempt to capture him for
further questioning right now there are
probably a million questions popping
into your head is the
scp-1780-1 office part of a branching
timeline are the entities within
foundation agents from an alternate
history trapped and displaced in time
well some of the answers we may never
know but some might be found in
scp-1780-3
the name given to a document that has
often also been found within the
scp-1780-1 office space much like the
rest of the furniture and stationary
inside scp-1780-1
this document seems to be from the scp
foundation itself printed on their
letterhead from around 1998.
the author of this document appears to
have been scp-1780-2a
dr thaddeus zynack himself somehow
either as an intentional booby-trap or
as some sort of side effect from the
temporal displacement of the office
scp-1780 has anomalous properties on the
reverse side of the paper after being
accidentally exposed to this effect a
foundation agent disappeared and was
presumed dead only to reappear within
the office space 14 years later as an
instance of scp-1780-2
appearing to have not physically changed
one bit in all that time as for the
contents of the
scp-1780-3 document it appears to be an
introductory letter and orientation
materials composed by dr thaddeus zynack
and intended for the special project
team investigating temporal anomalies
anyone that reads the full document has
suffered the same fate as the other
agent disappearing through unknown means
however the foundation has kept a hard
copy of the document in storage with the
reverse obscured to prevent its
anomalous effect an excerpt of dr
zynax's letter is also kept on file
available to read to those who hold
adequate security clearance in this
letter dr zynack explains that there are
in fact multiple different timelines
according to him of all the timelines to
exist many have their own version of the
scp foundation or another similar
organization but only a few of these
other alternate foundations have a
specific department dedicated to
studying time-based anomalies that is
why there is no temporal anomalies
department in the scp foundation as we
know it it could be possible that dr
thaddeus synack and all the other
scp-1780-2s are staffed from a different
version of the foundation that exists on
a different timeline the letter
continues as dr zynack claims that
everything you know about temporal
dynamics is fundamentally flawed despite
what even i might tell you paradoxes do
exist loosely defined a temporal paradox
is any situation arising from an
interpretation in an ordered sequence of
events which requires that two
contradictory outcomes be held as true
by the universe simultaneously that
sounds awfully verbose and complicated
but what he means is a time paradox
occurs when something disrupts the flow
of a timeline this then effectively
splits the timeline into two streams
creating a pair of similar yet slightly
different timelines that continue to
flow parallel with each other you see we
experience time as a single path a
straight line now imagine that path in
front of you had multiple other paths
branching off of it whichever way you
choose to walk a different choice means
you might have ended up walking on
another branch path that is similar but
will always be separate distinct and
different dr zinec then goes on to
outline the mission statement of his
temporal anomalies department their goal
is in essence to safeguard and protect
these various timelines they hope to
ensure that the events that led to the
existence of their department their
version of the scp foundation and even
humanity as a whole must always happen
as recorded by history from a base of
operations that is temporally isolated
existing outside time dr zynack and the
temporal anomalies department intend to
keep the history of human civilization
consistent and prevent any and all
possible future threats that might bring
about the end of the world as we know it
so there we have it scp-1780
an unassuming nameplate that opens a
portal to an office outside of time
itself an office belonging to a
foundation department that doesn't exist
in this timeline but whose mission is to
protect ours and every other branching
path of possibilities like we said
before time travel it's pretty
complicated now go check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation and
scp-5545 mysterious tunnels in
antarctica abnormality for more
mind-bending anomalies from the scp
foundation